hagamos algunos ejemplos relacionados
con fusiones sus dominios y rangos
recordemos que una función es un
operador digamos que tenemos la función
f y esta letra es la más común para
funciones que opera sobre una entrada en
este caso la entrada es x para producir
una salida que esto también lo podrías
ver como si tenemos una entrada x que
ingresas a una caja f que va a operar
sobre esto para producir una salida que
y el conjunto de valores que x puede
tomar eso se llama dominio es el
conjunto de valores válidos sobre los
que se puede operar ese es el dominio y
el conjunto de valores y que f puede
producir se denomina rango con esto en
mente establezcamos primero cuál es la
definición de la función correspondiente
para cada uno de estos problemas para
posteriormente encontrar cuáles son los
dominios y los rangos empecemos 25 obras
10 dólares la hora
déjame subrayar esto 10 dólares la hora
por
podar el césped entonces cuánto cobra en
función de las horas digamos entonces
que 25 obras llamaré la función de x 2
ting 25 obras como función de horas
depende de las horas la entrada de
nuestra caja va a ser horas que él
trabaja y esto va a ser igual a 10 por
el número de horas que trabaja 10 x no
va a poner el signo de por simplemente
10 h y por supuesto no puede trabajar
horas negativas así es que pondremos que
h es mayor o igual a cero esa es la
definición de nuestra función si
quisiera saber cuánto gana por ejemplo
si trabaja media hora pues sustituye es
un medio aquí lo cual básicamente es
sustituir esta h con un medio haces 10
por un medio déjame escribirlo aquí
abajo
así es que 2 tim va a cobrar por media
hora él va a cobrar 10 por el valor de h
aquí sustituimos un medio 10 por un
medio es igual a 5 dólares este la
definición de la función y aquí te estoy
mostrando un ejemplo de cómo aplicar la
encontremos ahora
y el rango empecemos con el dominio
el dominio bueno aquí de alguna manera
ya luís explícito no puedes trabajar las
negativas así que esta función no está
definida si h es menor que cero así
podemos establecer que son números no
negativos números no negativos y
podríamos decir que números reales que
incluyen números irracionales como el
número pi o el número e pero es un hecho
que no puedes cobrar algo así como diez
veces pi dólares no es una cantidad que
puedas cobrarle a alguien en la vida
real pues al final de cuentas vas a
tener que redondear le a centavos
no puedes de hecho cobrar eso así es que
cualquier cantidad que vayas a cobrar va
a tener que ser un número racional es
decir un número que puede expresarse
como una fracción por lo que no podemos
tomar números como é o pi así que para
ser realmente precisos en esto diremos
que tienen que ser números no negativos
racionales los cuales son aquellos
números que pueden ser expresados como
una fracción que son la mayoría los
números no incluye aquellos números cuya
expansión decimal no se repite como
ocurre con el número y el número pi así
que
y racionales no negativos es lo que
puede entrar aquí y entonces el rango
que son los valores posibles de salida
el rango
y de nueva cuenta aquí solo puedes tener
valores no negativos racionales no
negativos así que cualquiera que sea el
valor que ingreses como h vas a obtener
valores positivos de cuánto vas a cobrar
de 10 por h del valor de la función de
nueva cuenta entonces va a ser un valor
no negativo entonces va a ser un número
no negativo y si ingresas aquí un número
racional al ser expresado como una
fracción y multiplicarlo por 10 vamos a
obtener aún un número racional así que
el rango son números no negativos
racionales y si quisiéramos el más
preciso diríamos que son aquellos
números que pueden ser expresados con un
signo de dólar es bueno ya fuimos lo
suficientemente precisos ya tienes la
idea hagamos más de estos problemas
aquí tenemos mariah dando clases mariah
cobra 25 dólares la hora 25 dólares la
hora dando clases de matemáticas con un
cobro mínimo de 15 dólares entonces
maría cobra en función de las horas 15
dólares 15 dólares si no cubres la hora
completa si tenemos que son 25 dólares
la hora
para hacer 15 dólares tienes que
trabajar 15 25 a vos es decir tres
quintos de horas por lo tanto si las
horas que trabaja son menores o iguales
que tres quintos y mayores o iguales a
cero va a cobrar 15 dólares porque si
por ejemplo trabajar a un quinto de hora
el recibo sería de 5 dólares pero ella
especifica que tiene un cobro mínimo de
15 dólares entonces va a cobrar 15
dólares por hasta tres quintos de la
hora y 36 minutos después de eso para h
mayor a tres quintos va a cobrar 25
dólares la hora es decir 25 por h así
que aquí tenemos la definición de la
función y ahora bien cuál es el dominio
cuál es el dominio para la función de
cobro demaría de nueva cuenta esto es
sólo válido para valores no negativos
valores no negativos
dh y siguiendo el mismo razonamiento que
hicimos aquí realmente no podemos cargar
algo así como horas y horas tiene que
ser un número que pueda ser expresado
como fracción por ejemplo a un 5 si tú
consideras 5 horas eso también se puede
expresar como una fracción como 5 sobre
uno tenemos entonces números no
negativos racionales números no
negativos
racionales y cuál es entonces el rango
de esta función de cobro de mariah por
enseñar matemáticas bueno tiene que ser
al menos 15 dólares no importa cuánto
tiempo te da clases por lo menos va a
cobrar por lo menos 15 dólares entonces
el rango tiene que ser números
racionales
que sean mayores o iguales mayores o
iguales que 15 dólares no hay
posibilidad que cobre 14 dólares no hay
posibilidad que cobre menos un dólar no
importa cuál sea la situación siempre va
a cobrar por lo menos 15 dólares tenemos
ahora estas definiciones de funciones
más abstractas en las cuales puedes
ingresar prácticamente cualquier número
bueno números reales no estamos tratando
con complejos veamos si presentan alguna
restricción entonces si tenemos fx
déjame reescribir le aquí
fx es igual a 15 x menos 12 cuál es el
dominio cuál es el dominio de esta
función puede ser cualquier número real
aquí lo va a multiplicar por 15 y luego
lo guarde estar 12 puede ser el número
pi puede ingresar a raíz de 2 o puede
ingresar el número e puedo hacer
cualquier cosa que se me ocurra entonces
el dominio de esta función son todos los
números reales cualquier nuevo real que
tome como x va a proporcionar una salida
válida
y ahora cuál es el rango bueno de nueva
cuenta aquí puedo tener cualquier valor
puedo obtener cualquier valor negativo
si hago x suficientemente negativo la
función puede valer 0 o puede tomar
cualquier valor positivo puede tomar
cualquier número real por lo cual el
rango es todos los números reales
tenemos ahora esta función es fx es
igual a aquí se les olvidó el signo de
igual 2x cuadrada + 5 entonces cuál es
el dominio aquí
cuál es el dominio bueno yo puedo poner
cualquier valor aquí que se me ocurra
puedo poner el valor de esto sería 2 al
cuadrado más 5
puedo poner el valor de raíz de dos o
poner cualquier número negativo
cualquier número real
así es que todos los números
reales puede ser positivo o negativo e
inclusive irracional y ahora cuál es el
rango bueno esto es interesante porque
si te fijas no importa cuál número
tengas aquí esto va a ser siempre mayor
a cero este de aquí siempre va a ser no
negativo
porque no importa si tú tomas un número
negativo aquí lo vas a elevar al
cuadrado así es que te va a quedar
positivo así que esta expresión va a ser
no negativa si tú tienes un número no
negativo y se lo sumas a 5 siempre vas a
obtener un número que va a ser mayor o
igual a 5 en el peor de los casos si
esto es 0 esto va a ser 5 y si esto es
ligeramente menor a 0 o ligeramente
mayor a 0 vas a obtener valores mayores
que 5
entonces el rango es todos los números
reales
que son mayores o iguales que 5 está fx
nunca puede tomar el valor de 0 no hay
manera de que esto se haga 0 hagamos
ahora el problema número 5 problema
número 5 que tenemos aquí fx es igual a
1 entre x cuando es el dominio aquí
el dominio aquí de nueva cuenta es todos
los reales no importa qué número tú
tomes le puedes tomar el recíproco
entonces el dominio que iba a ser todos
los números reales y entonces cuál es el
rango esto es interesante también no
importa qué número pongo aquí puedo
obtener cualquier otro número a de hecho
tengo que ser muy cuidadoso aquí esto no
está definido cuando x es igual a 0 no
se puede tomar el recíproco de 0
entonces van a ser todos los reales que
son distintos de 0 si yo pongo 0 aquí
voy a tener uno entre 0
esto es indefinido déjame escribir esto
por acá acá si hago un error
efe de 0 está indefinido lo cual
literalmente significa que no sabemos
qué hacer con el 0 no hemos definido una
manera de operar sobre el cero así es
que fede 0 está indefinido entonces el
dominio es todos los reales
excepto el 0 y cuál es el rango bueno de
nueva cuenta este valor nunca puede ser
0 podemos tomar valores que sean muy muy
muy grandes de x y se va a acercar a 0 o
si x tiene valores muy muy
y esto también se acerca a 0 pero de
ninguna manera es posible que esto
llegue a ser 0 así de nueva cuenta todos
los reales
excepto el 0 todos los números reales
excepto el 0
bien problema número 6 cuál es el rango
de la función e igual a x cuadrada menos
5 cuando el dominio es cuando el dominio
es únicamente los números
- 2 - 1 0 1 y 2 en realidad esta función
debería quedar establecida como sigue
fx es igual a x cuadrada menos 5 para x
igual a deja de poner lo mejor de la
siguiente manera para x que es un
elemento del conjunto que consta de
menos 2 menos 10 1 y 2 no está definida
para x distinta que esto no sabríamos
qué hacer solo aplica si x es una de
estas entonces cuál es el rango el rango
son todos los valores que fx puede tomar
entonces el rango el rango son todos los
valores que puede tomar la función
cuando ingresamos los distintos valores
de x evaluamos en toda la función con el
primero con menos dos menos dos al
cuadrado menos cinco menos dos al cuadro
es 4 menos 5 - 1
sigamos ahora con menos uno menos uno al
cuadrado menos cinco menos uno al
cuadrado es uno menos 5
4 vayamos ahora con 0 0 al cuadrado efe
de 0 es 0 al cuadrado menos 5 es igual a
menos 5 continuamos con 1 1 al cuadrado
menos 5 es menos 4 que ya tenemos en el
rango y finalmente todos al cuadrado
menos 5 es igual a menos 1 ya incluido
en el rango así que estos son todos los
valores que puede tomar esta función
dado que la hemos restringido a tan solo
estas entradas